herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
mathis mit mir am start heute leute
begrüße euch herzlich zu der
wahrscheinlich krassesten serie die es
jemals auf einem kanal gab und in kölner
dom leute und er hat den titel von dem
video auch gesehen wir werden jetzt eine
woche lang mit sieben euro pro tag
auskommen nicht nur auskommen überleben
nein wir machen urlaub eine woche lang
weil wir durch deutschland unterwegs
sein und sieben euro pro tag versuchen
irgendwie klar zu kommen und sagen wir
die ganzen tag mit dem sommer der
deutschen bahn die deutsche bahn hat mir
max und dave hinter der kamera der film
ein sommer gegeben mit dem können wir
vier fahrten durch ganz deutschland
machen und wir machen uns auf den weg
von köln nach hamburg
okay wir sind im zug hier sind hier
drüben der zug wird uns da hannover
beschränken dann um und fahren nach
hamburg genau wir haben es heute morgen
noch mal richtig die folge haben weil
das war quasi das letzte mal dass wir
einfach essen konnten was wir wollten
weil ab sofort müssen wir uns wirklich
aufs geld schauen themen sprechen wenn
ihr wahrscheinlich das nächste mal auch
erstmals ersten bände in hamburg bei
unseren kumpel lennart angekommen sind
bei dem wir auch übernachten werden für
zwei nächte wir müssen natürlich bei
dieser reise immer irgendwo unterkommen
weil bei 7 euro ist natürlich kein
übernachtungs mit dabei dementsprechend
vor eine familie wir haben sie alle
angehauen und müsste mal geben leute
also sieben euro sagte vielleicht so ok
in unserem alltag sieben euro ist okay
so mache ich vielleicht jeden tag ok im
alltag ist das eine sache wenn meine
küche alles aber wir sind im urlaub
das müsst ihr euch mal geben sieben euro
für alles jeden einzigen tag des geistes
kann sich die stadt jetzt ja nicht wie
es überhaupt hinter und sollte aber das
wird machen werden ist wir werden
erstmal eure taschen komplett lernen
damit ihr auch wisst ob wir haben
wirklich nicht mehr geld macht natürlich
nie war kein problem ist wie du bist
draußen
ich habe noch ein bisschen was von der
sache ist leute ihr müsst dazu auch
wissen nur max und ich leben mit sieben
euro am tag der hinter der kamera darf
immer so viel aus wir werden über uns
lachen muss natürlich bei kräften
bleiben damit eine kamera so gut halten
kann
du bist ja danke semester ich habe ein
bisschen ergeben gibt mir was ich für
gespanne also mit skip das ist unser
budget der sexuellen wünschen gesammelt
damit es gleich zurück
denn du bist unser schatzmeister und der
einzige mensch der bei ausgelassen
wohl auch deswegen bitte wollt ihr euer
besteht für den ersten tag
okay wir starten mit sieben euro für
sebastian
es wird euch dass das ist alles was ich
jetzt eine woche lang für jeden tag habe
für alles mit 1 90 groß 90 kilo
nach sportlich fressen wie ein
scheunendrescher und spd urlaub sicher
ich muss los
ich bin kurz ich kann damit der
legendäre staatsmeister
mal gestanden der nicht mit youtube wird
oft als schön
das ding ist auch das einstein geht also
dann für den urlaub
[Musik]
der airbus 330 g geworden unser halbes
tages in hannover während in europa ein
zwischenstopp auf dem weg nach hamburg
wir müssen nur einen kurzen schauer
nicht an die deutsche bahn geben ihren
haben einfach gesagt okay wenn man so
drei junge du liest sich max & day und
wir geben einfach ein ticket und lassen
die deutschlandfahnen drei videos machen
wenn die serie mit drei videos und das
ganze wird so laufen kurz bevor ich wir
haben 13 leute in deutschland ausgesucht
der erstes hamburg das wisst ihr schon
die anderen beiden sind noch geheim
werdet ihr aber in den nächsten videos
sehen wir werden eine woche über wie es
kann eben schon gesagt habe mit sieben
euro pro tag urlaub machen müssen
wir haben das vergessen was ihr habt mir
zweier bargeld gegeben
aber was ist mit euren ganzen
kreditkarten und ich habe ganze arbeit
und eure ganzen kam ein pizza aber hier
wird ich habe immer noch das ganze geld
nicht ausgegeben bei musste jetzt
höllisch aufpassen
vorbereitung ist die leute ich hab
natürlich zu hause schon meine youtube
trinkt verstauen und leer getrunken
misst bisher sind wir beide noch bei 7
euro kein cent ausgegeben langsam kommt
der hunger aber wir hatten aber noch
durch das haben wird noch eine stunde
zukauf weiter geht
[Musik]
es geht schneller als gedacht dauernden
einer freistunde von
jetzt weiß ich was heute zu acht stunden
nach hamburg mainz und hamburg die
grafische geändert vor ihrem bruder und
ich habe bis zum durstig gesagt meine
wasserflasche ist der seit zwei stunden
praxis mit auch zur neige
wir haben seit sechs stunden nichts
gegessen
ich habe mich schon das heißt wir gehen
gleich einkaufen oder gingen einkaufen
dann gucken wir gar nicht alle ganz
genau ich habe mir schon etwas überlegt
wo wir nicht allzu viel geld ausgeben
müssen
lasst uns das jetzt machen
das ist eine tiefe vor
ja wiederholen
dass seine agenda gastgeber für die für
die nächste kamera zwei nächte besteht
meine kamera so begeistert von dem er
sagt
übrigens sollten die kosten 7 euro ist
alles also übernachtungen dann vor
ersten spaß alles alles was sie machen
sieben euro nicht dass ausgenommen ist
einzig dass ausgaben für das ticket dass
wir schon haben deswegen könnt ihr euren
freunden übernachten sondern bezahlen
von sieben euro gericht aber der bringt
unter dem entsprechenden absoluter eben
gott dafür würde jetzt ok lassen
bekommen wir dann hier
wir müssen unsere ersten ausgaben
verbuchen und von bestimmten
gesamtbudget abziehen
willst du mit seinem supermarkt 6 eur 66
seht ihr auch widerwillig hier also auch
das ganze teile durch hier denn wir
haben ein kilo nudeln habe ja gesehen
zwei punkten thunfisch und gefüllte
tonne an ärzten vier personen essen
davon 666 durch 41 66,5 das heißt wir
ziehen gesamtbudget sich hier drüben
maxein eur 67 ab und sebastian 1 760
update wie geil ist das denn das
halbjahr die größte mahlzeit des tages
für 1 eur 65 die fotos mit begannen sie
ihre atmung
ja wie pipi ist alle lieb dankeschön
später leute ihr seht mich in einer
komatösen position im bett liegen aber
wir haben verstärken erhalten
mittlerweile toll wird
er ist wieder ein kumpel von uns das im
monat hier ist dann die nordiren da
können wir auch felix herth felix ist
auch im hamburger und ist zu uns
gekommen und ja und das beste ist leute
wir haben uns sogar einen abendprogramm
zusammen gefädelt auf irgendeine weise
markt was machen wir haben wir gehen
erst mal eine bar und danach in einen
club und für beide ist müssen wir nun
euro eintritt zahlen von müssen halt
schauen wie wir mit unserem budget klar
kommen das heißt wahrscheinlich gibt es
leid und wasser für uns ich hoffe wir
sind keine spaßbremsen aber stellte er
die drei der felix denn so eine geile
zeit haben wir wasser vielleicht kein
geschissen wer sollte die sache jetzt
mag es nicht wenn wir beide noch fünf
euro 50 ziemlich genau das 530 wir beide
noch übrig von dem ssv keeper ausgehen
können also so etwas wie wasser sind
vielleicht können uns irgendwas können
also wenn wir jetzt nicht zum club wir
können ein eis essen gehen wir können
eine waffel essen gehen becker wir haben
möglichkeiten 55 wurde wird sollte das
gute ist ja uns halt alle 250 gramm
nudeln pro nase reingepresst möchte man
etwas sagen im moment müssen wir heute
nichts mehr hessen so glaube ich bekommt
auch keinen hunger mehr also sie mir
quasi erstmals fällt mit dem essen heute
unsere fünf euro 30 einsätzen für drei
zähler übrig okay leute nächsten morgen
sie wahrscheinlich noch hier im bett wir
haben sehr gut geschlafen danke nochmal
ländern für seine gastfreundschaft die
habe ich gestern beide im klub noch
jeweils für vier euro ein getränk geholt
das ist eigentlich nicht vorgesehen aber
dadurch dass es frühstück im voraus
gemacht haben konnten wir uns das
erlauben und gibt es jetzt wieder unsere
sieben euro wir gehen frühstück
einkaufen und starten den tag so wurde
jetzt geht's wieder ans tagesbeginn für
die beiden irgend wie viele war es
nochmal acht euro
meine sieben euro
frühstück ist
das relativ früh jungs vom einkauf
zurück und es wird zeit für unser
frühstück soll natürlich ein bisschen
los aus sie habe ich begonnen geist das
kannte nur haben ja seit gestern
nachmittag nichts mehr gegessen auch
wenn es gestern eine große portion aber
wo ist da jetzt was du hast gesagt ich
war natürlich einfach glücklich sind ja
ist jemandem gut schießen wird es mit
einer zahl von rund ums verpacken boot
gekauft so dass wir heute abend auf
jeden fall noch davon speisen können das
doch ich denke sagte allofs frühstück
machen lustigerweise 6 eur 67 gekostet
also ein cent mehr als sie einfach von
mir standen will nur dass wir durch drei
teilen nicht durch vier aber wir haben
ja auch fürs abendessen quasi mit
gesorgt weil das werden wir nicht alles
jetzt auch essen und diese zustände oder
dave der abgerufen hat sich eiskalt
thomas geholt und einen fonds kaufen gab
es von ich lebe das good life ich hab
mir tomaten gekauft natürlich war der
test jetzt meistens greenpeace muss ein
bisschen schwarz geworden ist ja das
gesunde frühstück was es gibt leute aber
wir können uns war schon geil billigsten
brot genau diese ganze packung 9 50 cent
kostet der billigste käse ja auch nicht
so perfekt ist weil zum teil aber das
wird mir richtig perfekt und haben
aber so also für windräder
[Musik]
die leute ganz wichtig jetzt
informationen für euch noch zu dem
ticket mit dem wir endlich rum fahren
ist das sogenannte sommerticket das
beinhaltet vier fragen die euch frei
wählen können durch ganz deutschland
wenn ja unter 18 seid kostet eine fahrt
[Musik]
okay wir sind aus der wohnung raus und
mein gott wir waren gestern abend alle
die bis am abend schon recht voll
eingeplant
heute morgen haben wir uns dann diese
greenpeace sandwiches gemacht wie einen
zug geisteskrank ausgeknockt haben dann
erst mal zwei stunden gezockt und jetzt
leute ich hätte nicht gedacht dass wir
es machen gehen wir einen döner essen
weil wir haben für abend also für
frühstück und abendessen gerade
eingekauft das heißt wir noch viel geld
übrig und können uns einfach einen döner
können und das ist wirklich special weil
ich glaube das machen wir nicht allzu
oft let's go dünner
ich sehe ich in mir
was trinkt
deutlich freue mich so darauf der ja bis
drei tische andere nahrung könnte
more gesamte buch heftig so eine galerie
auf haben
die sache ist heute man muss komplett
ankommt zeigen dass man sich irgendwo
was zu essen holt fertig gibt's ab man
kann sich natürlich dass größeren bäcker
holen weil es zu teuer da geht immer die
gleichen und quasi von den menschen mit
seinen hier wird einfach zu teuer ist
kabarett talk das hier ist ein kleiner
dünner also davon wird auf jeden fall
sagt von heute abend gibt es dann halt
noch mal bot aber geil was können
[Musik]
alles da heute blicke später wir haben
unseren dünner verdaut und sind jetzt
hier in einem bach das ist der geilste
tag den ich jemals gesehen habe in
meinem leben wirklich land hin und
blumen in hamburg heißt das aber egal da
gibt es das hier fängt gerade antreten
und wir haben uns einen trance überlegt
und zwar gibt es hier diesen weg der
über diesen kleinen see führt und wir
werden um einen euro spiel zu erinnern
und wie haben beide noch ungefähr 1 eur
30 de h denn der weg ist aber nur noch
30 cent eine andere zwei euro 30 werden
wir spielen wäre es schneller scharf von
einem ende
natürlich ohne reinzufallen und die
gefahr einzufallen ist relativ hoch
jetzt 21
[Musik]
für zurück
ca
stopp
wir sind 53 das ist schon schnell
das ist schnell hier ich bin am 21
dann nämlich vor langsam gefügt aber hey
das war nicht ich sagte merkel
das ist halt schon der leute das ist ein
krasser unterschied so ich hab einfach
gerade mein bein tages budget verdoppelt
ich habe wirklich ein saftiges alten du
hast noch 30 cent für den heutigen tag
der hersteller kein gekonnt durch das
alter ihre dunkle schokolade von meinem
bruder serviert für meinen bruder dürft
ihr euch nichts also ich nicht von
meinem bruder max er jetzt nicht das
einzige sein der typ da drin aber
korrekt hätte mir das als ihren max
krieg natürlichkeit setzt google hat
einen 60 kostet nicht nur eingeblendet
und das alte backhaus glaube ich so das
ist so
mit dem max hatte 30 - 60 für das habe
ich von 70 cent für den tag genug und
max hat noch 30 sind und kann
[Musik]
jetzt gerade sind wir im so genannten
central park assist im schanzenviertel
in hamburg uebel stylist küttel nicht
weit von hier ist die rote flora megabit
lustigerweise auch für alle rockfans
soll das tattoo studio von 17
straßenbahnen ist auch in der nähe wir
sind einfach durch über die straße
gelaufen haben so bones von 17 getroffen
und alexandra 7 betroffen aber ja mit
diesem zettel park die jungs ein
bisschen tischtennis dass wir hier sein
dürfen nicht selber werden laut dass
damit eine ehre euch hier zu werben als
reisen schritt für euch auf jeden fall
massenpanik ausgelöst
so leute gestern abend und heute morgen
haben wir noch
zum frühstück gestern gegessen wir
mussten jetzt gerade leider und von
lennart verabschieden wenn du das siehst
länder durch schon mal danke schön dass
wir bei dir sein durften wir begeben uns
jetzt zum hauptbahnhof und von da geht
es zu unserem nächsten ziel
okay leute wie gesagt wir befinden uns
jetzt im hauptbahnhof wir beenden das
erste video von unserem projekt hiermit
als nächstes geht es weiter nach heute
wahrscheinlich gern wissen aber dafür
müssen die eigenschaften der nächsten
videos habe bisher weder viel spaß
gemacht ok und dann sehen wir im
nächsten video genau hier wieder